usually when we play music together we
like to record it this weekend we're
like you know what would be really cool
what if you had a cool 360 audio device
or something like that
we kind of evolved into like Oh binaural
audio what is binaural audio anyways
well binaural audio it translates
literally into two ears you know from
the perspective of your ears audio and
you actually can get binaural
microphones which actually look like two
little ears and they're really cool but
they're a little expensive they're about
600 bucks but one of the materials with
the form - it's a flexible material I
haven't used it yet but I'm figuring I
could probably make my own binaural
microphone by printing out flexible 3d
printed ears and using our tiny little
lot of microphones placed inside of each
one we'll see what this goes climate
change is a result of human activity is
responsible for exponential increase in
global temperature from extreme to even
worse if that's possible
California suffers through an
unprecedented drought that we've been
covering over half the state now facing
the most severe conditions yeah it's
gonna droughts not only in Southern
California but also down here in the
studio when we were over in Studio five
I don't know some bottles got lost in
the transition and we've been out of
water for a couple weeks now it's not
good I'm going over there to steal
whatever I can get you know coming back
with gallons at a time I've been
stealing monsters from over there I mean
just don't know what to do man I'm
parched
I have taken my ear' 3d model of choice
six hours and 19 minutes so basically
it's here it's a small square plate on
the back and then it's a quarter inch
hole through the ear canal and the base
so that way I can slip up microphone
through it print Y in air well if you
think about it everything you hear is
through
year so if you create a microphone that
is shaped like your ear it brings you
that much closer to how you'd actually
experience the sound all I know is that
this thing's got flexible material
I got a 3d model of an ear so let's do
it okay listen up hopefully it's not
complete failure it doesn't look like
it's a failure which is why I love this
[ __ ] printer wow it's like a polygon
here it's like an 80s retro here this
turned out really well actually
mmm oh he's so squishy here we go ear
give you a little bath with your duckies
well that works out really well I'm
gonna mark that as a success I'm going
to go back to my computer mirror it and
print out the other ear I stopped using
that door because if you use that door
you have to come through and then
everyone sees you this door it's the
fastest way in and out to the water
then is there someone right at the
gaming consoles right it's at the door
that was close
it's all about making casual
conversation but really your whole
mission is for that goodness Jake can
have some water I'm so thirsty it turned
out really really nice it's very rubbery
kind of like sinks in you can squeeze it
bend it twist it and it kind of just
like all reforms flexible material isn't
quite like human cartilage kind of soft
that being said this is a lot more ideal
than having a really brittle hard ear
the acoustics of something that is soft
and it can absorb sound is much
different than a very hard reflective
surface this is the closest
approximation that we can build here to
a person's ear I guess the next step
here is to clip off all this excess junk
all the excess supports and test it out
just imagine doing this to someone's
real here
with pinchers there we go there we have
it got a little cleanup to do on their
still but for the most part there we go
Hey
I can taste it already came here you get
been expecting you no no no
oh you guys just water
this one turn on scream that's testing
okay something's wrong
yep good call this is me there you go
just on me good you're right here yeah
number three is left so how do I carry
all this garbage around
I'm just got to jank it like this just
hold it still okay this is technically
all functioning right now hello how are
you
a little sonic tour through the studio
Hey ooh what an acoustic difference I
have no idea if this is even gonna work
or sound right but okay so I'm just
listen to it
you'll hear it okay it functions as
intended right now I'm pretty surprised
with when you face the ears and the
camera at a subject the voice or the
whatever subject you're looking at and
focusing out with ears is actually
pretty pronounced instead of like
hearing this stuff you're actually
hearing the stuff in front of you you
know that's the ears natural shape I
think the real test is taking the little
mics and taking ears off of it I'm just
like having them sit there
yeah they sing outwards and doing like a
blah blah blah blah blah and standing
around it and then putting ears on it
and then doing the same thing and
hearing how it shapes it just a little
bit differently what if my ears were
really out to there if you were gonna
look at me so weird tomorrow what's at
stake if I don't succeed my dignity